I think vision is as many problems as it
has is here now and has many of the same
advantages that Fusion does the fact
that traditional fission nuclear is
having so much difficulty and is so
expensive relative to other forms of
energy is kind of a sign that even if we
do manage to get a fusion power plant in
the next 30 years it's not going to be a
Panacea it's certainly economically a
lot of problems to overcome that if
successful Fusion could allow unlimited
energy to not only produce energy but to
decarbonize as I understand it could
decarbonize the planet and reverse
global warming not just halt it did you
ever encounter threats let me just be
totally blunt did you ever feel you were
threatened in any way career-wise
intellectually or otherwise
foreign